um
well you messaged me
he messaged me to apologize you know
he was like hey ed uh i saw that episode
with you
on davidson's genius brain and
i just want to say i'm sorry you know
because i was
a jerk and like full of you know his
head was really big
because he was doing really well as an
artist at the time in
five four three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast
if this is your first time listening to
the podcast
this podcast is about everything and
everything
basically yeah i mean that i just heard
your china mac
podcast that was so [ __ ] crazy let me
tell you something everything
my ass was sweating throughout the whole
podcast
blown away it's one of my favorite
episodes you've had you know what's
interesting about that
it's he
[Music]
i don't know if i ever have an objective
when i do a podcast right yeah
but uh i knew stuff about him obviously
before the podcast i just didn't know
these stories in depth yeah right so
when he was saying people were like oh i
thought you already knew who he was he's
like yeah i know
the story is here and there but he's
going into detail it's blowing my
[ __ ] mind
because i'm not gonna research him all
the way i want there to be discovery on
this podcast as well
acting like this is first we feast like
you're gonna like shock him something he
doesn't you know about him that he
didn't
interesting [ __ ] you know you did your
research
it's crazy because your father's here
right now
she just walks
[Laughter]
when he came on the podcast it was kind
of dope to see this dude who
people talk about believing in reform
yeah
but they but they don't really get to
see it right
right you know and one of the biggest
takeaways that i actually had from that
podcast was that
his biggest catalyst for change was his
mom
right and now i see why he's so
angry when he sees all these asian
attacks yeah
he sees his mom yeah all the time the
one person that believed in him even
when he was in prison
his friends his family his gang none of
that [ __ ] nobody checked in on him
except for his mother
and so now he's in this position where
he actually projects a lot of this rage
because he
sees his mother being in that same
position
she lives in new york she walks around
and imagine that happening to his mom
right and people just stand around and
[ __ ] that vulnerability
was scary that's scary it's like oh man
look at him he's he's opening up yeah
like what are you what you supposed to
do
you know yeah but then like you know
masculine
like uh vulnerability is a positive
real thing like i should be this way but
you know
like the the back of our mind is that
we're gonna laugh at this because
you know oh that's chyna mac and
whatever but man
that's just [ __ ] realness yeah yeah
and his anger was
so real with it right like i said this
once on the
just kidding news like um you know when
i'm laughing about my [ __ ]
like the other thing i'm gonna do if i
don't laugh is cry
what other options are there because you
know these are these are tragedies or
it's like the i mentioned the you know
those drama faces
like and like you see the crying face
and the laughing face
i never understood that until like later
in life where it's like you experience a
tragedy or trauma or whatever
and you can look at it and you have two
options man
like laugh or be angry and cry
you know it's just like it's just a
coping mechanism to how we deal with
drama in our lives right yeah and it's
just like all those emotions are
so real and that's why this podcast is
so dope
because you know people will come in
with an agenda right and they put on a
character
right and a voice when they talk to you
that was so [ __ ] real
yeah man like getting to know him was
was was a real blessing because it's
like i've i've known people kind of
like him right but that's when i was a
lot younger
and i haven't been able to reconnect
with some of these dudes uh now that i'm
older it's been like what 15
10 15 years i haven't seen these guys i
don't know what they're up to i don't
know if they're reformed some of these
dudes are in prison some of them are
dead
so it's to see this guy to uh
i mean obviously he still has like his
his you know
his upbringing is still how he speaks
and you know how he views the world
which is all there you know a lot of
people might agree or disagree with his
approach
but for him to be able to explain that
nuance was very important right
because he was also talking about on the
podcast how
i think a lot of people wonder why he uh
he chooses violence right they go what
do you mean like why can't i
you just speak up about things he goes
well that's not how i grew up yeah when
he was
in the group homes and stuff the moment
people stopped [ __ ] with him was when
he physically had to stand up for
himself people were
spitting gum in his hair slapping him
upside the head and he goes the moment i
started [ __ ] people up is when they
started respecting me yeah
and that's just the world that he comes
from and you know for me too i was
trying to get
my point was to was like i agree with
him but you know not all the time
you know just different worlds i i bring
it up every now and then with two close
friend
and i do believe in violence you know
and that's just because of my upbringing
too
like because i had to survive around
these [ __ ] races
you know through middle school high
school or whatever um
and yeah if if i fought back
um yeah a lot of people would say don't
[ __ ] with him he knows kung fu
that's tight yeah and straight i do
and you just
did i tell you this story this this
regular black customer he's a really
good
friend of my dad's from back in the day
and then every now and then he'd come in
and call me jimmy because that's what he
called my dad but
because i look like him and you just
slip up one day i asked him because
you know we're in [ __ ] rural area
there's nobody around he's like
one of six black people in the
neighborhood and
i just i was at the end of my rope
pretty much with the [ __ ] that was
going on
and i just asked him behind the counter
and i was like hey man how do you how
long have you lived here he's like
uh close to like 25 years he has a
really raspy voice
like how do you deal with these people
man these people are [ __ ] crazy and
racist
and goes you know what i do i [ __ ] them
up
[ __ ] yeah he goes he just looks me and i
he goes next time one of these mothers
[ __ ] [ __ ] with you
[ __ ] them up you know and then you're
like dude that's a really good aquafina
impression
i think you got a little hairball i
her voice always shocks me every time
it's like damn girl you need a lozenge
maybe a couple glass of water or
something
lemon somebody eleven i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is we gotta lube that [ __ ]
up baby
but yeah when people you saw that video
of the lady getting punched in the face
right
you know i did it on okay because he
said it too like
he's tired of like the next shark
that asian dawn and jackfruit or
whatever
i had to stop following that um it's
news
yeah it's it's it's stuff we should know
it eats at you though it eats at me
it gives me crazy i'll start shaking
i'll have a little sweat
and just get [ __ ] angry and there's
nothing i can do about it you know
you know it's weird right because now
they're floating into this weird space
of
am i doing this because i'm trying to
raise awareness or because
it's is it a mix of that and also
because it gets views and eyes views
eyes clicks shares you know
and with no end game like okay yeah
there's a
exactly there but there's a donation
link i guess
but then it's like in my heart i
want justice you know like um
and so as he was saying that that's what
i appreciated about your part
was that you weren't trying to debate
him and argue
with him like no we need to be peaceful
and whatever it's like
he was truly expressing himself these
are real human feelings
are they progressive are they nice
are are they actual solutions maybe not
that's
there's a debate behind that but that's
what i why i think it's one of my
favorite episodes because he was being
so real
yeah and there's there's no point in me
telling him how he should deal with his
own personal situations right because
a lot of people think things in black
and white yeah there's this huge gray
area in between
right and when you get to hear his story
and how he has dealt with his adversity
and listen when you look at the video
right if you see the video of that woman
being attacked it's actually
heartbreaking i've seen a lot of videos
but i'm talking about this guy
he's deranged he's crazy as it always is
comes up and he punches this lady so
hard on the face she actually knocks out
dead
cold like slumped over on a pole
like this just knocked out lean just
completely laid out
and the hard part about that video and
we talked about on the podcast
was watching how listen i understand and
i've been in that position before i've
told this story on this podcast where i
saw somebody get robbed in front of me
and then by the time they were gone i
was like wait
i mean i get there's a shock factor yeah
there's like this it's like it's just
the bystander effect or something like
that i forgot what the
exact terminology is but
i think when we see that and you know
from the world that he comes from
he expects rage and retaliation right
yeah but instead
you see people just going up to the lady
like hey are you okay kind of
after about like 30 or 40 seconds and
they look at this guy and they do
nothing to the dude and they just let
him just stand there and watch this lady
as she's knocked down on the floor
so it's it's hard to watch and look i'm
i'm always talking about how there's
different generations that people would
have dealt with things differently
i don't think i would have been a part
of that though i think i would have
knocked that dude out cold
yeah it's just i can't i can't sit there
and watch that [ __ ] i
knocked him out cold or take him to the
floor and had his hands behind his back
or something
just you can't just let them get away
with it i mean um
a long time ago i think it was just
close to 10 years ago
um there was a youtuber he was at ucla
and it was like a prank kind of thing um
and he was faking like he was a bully
and he was bullying this dude straight
up like pushing around taking his back
just
demeaning him and but in the video
like it's ucla there's hella asia kids
watching it happen
and walking away and by the end he's
like what the [ __ ] is going
on yeah why isn't anyone doing anything
and in the comments it became a thing
about how
asians don't [ __ ] stand up for
anything right yeah
and i was pissed i was like hey man you
were in this situation
where these people's cultures are and
now 10 years later and this [ __ ] is
really really happening
and then i had it happen in my life i
see where he stands with that anger it's
just like
don't you guys care yeah yeah you know i
i was saying the same thing with
uh when i'm experiencing this crazy kind
of [ __ ] trauma where
i have to be on my toes because somebody
wants to [ __ ] fight me
someone's assault me or say some racist
[ __ ]
i go to church because i need to see
some korean faces
then realize that they don't [ __ ]
care
you know i show up and i post all these
crazy videos on my instagram
and then just be like dang that's crazy
that's it dude help me
i wonder if it's like
they look at that and they go i have to
worry about my own stuff right because
i wonder like if the asian culture has
to do with
you know dealing with what's like
pertinent in terms of
you know making money taking care of my
personal family versus like well that
stuff is gonna work out you know
because we we trust our government the
the police will take care of it
i understand that on a macro level
because we said this over the shootings
in atlanta like we
are literally almost 2000 miles away
like plus yeah
we what can we exactly do but these were
like
these were supposedly my friends i see
these people every week
that's crazy so
my mom's like why you so angry
be nice
[Music]
exactly and so i i see why
china mac was also explaining like
that's the street i grew up on
like i like age did old chinese dude
that just kind of
sit around it's like we see them kind of
thing loitering or whatever but then to
see them do
nothing is art like hard he said he
wanted to go up and smack every single
[ __ ] one of them
yeah and and i do feel that way too it
it does put me in a state of like
disappointment
like you couldn't do anything like i'm
not asking you to kill the guy but
refrain him like check up on her a
little
faster i don't know man it makes us like
fit the stereotype though doesn't it
that [ __ ]
weak kind of asian male stereotype of
doing nothing about it you know when you
when you bring up that whole
and like in college too i remember there
was this um
when i went to ucr uh was the first time
i went to a university you know i lived
in a very small bubble going to college
was a really big deal for me right
even though it was ucr it was any it was
a university that would accept me
and ucr i think has i think in terms
like the diversity poll is a lot bigger
than
a lot of these other universities in
california right and just this one time
and i mentioned the story before what
just to kind of go back to that point
where i watched this kid
it was outside of the the commissary
room right where we get food
but there was these two white dudes that
were bullying this one asian kid and
you know they knew who he was they went
to high school together before they went
to college
yeah i don't know whether this kid and
the thing about it was i got so
[ __ ] mad and i remember i walked up
shoved the dude and whatever
and i started threatening to do and the
guy was like whoa we're just [ __ ]
joking around blah blah
blah i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out before i
beat the [ __ ] ass i'm [ __ ] pissed
and i look at the asian guy and i was
more mad at the asian dude than i was at
the two white boys yeah because he just
stood there and i just i
if i saw that kid now i could still
remember what he [ __ ] looked like
because of how pissed i was at him yeah
because he wouldn't do anything i looked
at him i was like dude the next time you
do some stupid [ __ ] i'ma beat your
[ __ ] ass too
threatening this kid too cause i'm so
[ __ ] mad because he's letting these
two white boys
just punk them for no [ __ ] reason he
and he was taking it
yeah and i'm like you got to stand up
for yourself and i you know and that
also has to do with me
my problem with like projecting my
younger self onto him when i was a kid
that used to happen to me too and that
[ __ ] stopped when i stood up for myself
and i've said this before a million
times on this podcast when i was a kid
if even if i got bullied for being the
fat kid with glasses i was gonna make
sure that i was the most difficult kid
to bully
you'll probably move on to somebody else
and it really did happen that way yeah
so when i saw that kid that asian kid
just
you know having these ching chong jokes
that had said to him getting pushed
against this locker and i'm like bro
stand up for us like these aren't even
that [ __ ] big and then when i shoved
this [ __ ] guy
with all of my [ __ ] might he was like
oh what the hell i'm just joking
a little [ __ ] [ __ ] and i was like
that's all you had to do and you
couldn't do it
and it's just a reflection of us as
males maybe it's a reflection of me and
like i see him representing me as well
you know i don't know
this podcast is brought to you by better
help if you haven't focused on your
mental health this year now is the time
to start listen
we've been cooped up tense and honestly
we know the importance of our mental
health so let's stop pushing our
thoughts emotions and feelings aside
and get the help we need see betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
message your counselor at any time
while setting up weekly video phone
sessions is super convenient and more
importantly
it allows you to be safe in your own
comfortable
environment and that personally helps me
a lot i've used better help and it was
honestly amazing
and i get to talk to my counselor
whenever i need them so give it a try
you have nothing to lose it's super
convenient
give it a go my friend so remember this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
geniusbrainlisters get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
genius though i mean i told you i was
part of ywam right
yeah and their headquarters is in kona
hawaii okay right it's a really big
like campus and like
on certain certain quarters it's like 50
korean because uh i guess koreans is the
second um uh
was a country largest company or per
capita
country to send out missionaries next to
the usa okay and then it's like norway
or something
and so on this base there's just be
hella koreans from korea
and all the korean americans are like
[ __ ]
like bad kids that their parents forced
them out of course this thing
like what a [ __ ] cigarette yeah so
exactly we'd go
is this yeah of course but um
one of my friends uh who went through
he's a pastor now but he's all tatted up
he went to jail and [ __ ]
um he's from atlanta he was telling me
like when he was taking classes there
too like
it was one of those quarters where it's
just like a bunch of koreans and you
know they play basketball too
so um they've had basketball games and
then
he said he just saw one of those white
kids just be like
do you know how to play basketball
basketball you know what this is huh
huh and like just patronizing him like
and just
being a major douche and these are
[ __ ] missionaries and christians
my god you know and he did the same he
went up to that kid and he's like what
are you doing
what the [ __ ] are you doing like he just
let it out he's like if i
ever see you do that again i will
[ __ ] kick your ass
and he said he turned to the korean guy
and he started yelling at him in korean
to stand up for himself too
and they almost kicked him out like my
friend out for being that way
instead of the [ __ ] white kids that
are so [ __ ] racist on that
crazy thing you hear me why wham kona
you have a [ __ ] racism problem
i hope you guys and all your friends who
know why women is
let them know there's a [ __ ] racism
pro problem there man
how weird is that how that happens is
where this person
person who was you know being a little
racist [ __ ] had they like oh well this
guy's too aggressive it's like hold on a
second what's the reason why this
happened
like people don't ever look into that
[ __ ] it's just such an odd thing because
it's acceptable
yeah you know they're like what's the
problem here and it's unacceptable for
us to be angry
yeah well he was just asking him if he
knew how to play a little basketball
like what the [ __ ] and it's like yeah
how do we
then when we see that kind of behavior
right how do we come to trust them then
how do we start to begin to trust you
like i'm supposed to
be on missions with these people you
know and one of the guys in my class was
from virginia
hardcore southern pride dude wow like uh
dixie flag everything you know
volleyball courts like i'm sitting on
the bleachers with him and i'm just
questioning him and like hey man why do
you rock that [ __ ] so hard yeah it's
like it's not
racist it's heritage
well your hair is racist it's [ __ ]
racist man
it was about states rights yeah you're
right to keep slaves
yeah you [ __ ] dummy they never they
don't actually [ __ ] know a goddamn
thing about what the hell is going on
like from then they they like literally
sweeping on the run she's like this is
my culture
i would there's there's even certain
towns like there's a
i mean you guys could probably correct
me if i'm wrong about this but there was
a place
near sacramento called el dorado hills
and i think like their their
the mascot of this thing was somebody on
a noose because it was called hang town
wow and you know it was the same
argument it's like
while you're trying to take down her
hair i got this
man hanging right here what's the
problem oh my god
what do you mean like i get it just put
it in the [ __ ] museum yeah you know
you don't have to put it in the [ __ ]
the center of the town dude put it in
the [ __ ] museum
and in that area too um like they found
out the realtors
that there's a certain clause when
people were buying homes i mean it
didn't affect who the home buyers were
but they didn't review
um the rules of the town in over like a
hundred years yeah and el dorado hills
at the time was like a mining town or
some [ __ ] like a pit stop or something
and um one of the the rules was that
there was no black people allowed to
live in the neighborhood
and when you read the contract or when
you were signing the papers for the
neighborhood of the area
it was still there that there was no
black people all out like negroes
weren't allowed
like you know this hush this the history
of this country is
it's it's embedded here and you know we
we talk about this the slavery wasn't
that long ago
yeah and on top of that too like just
basic decent human rights given to
people of color
was only given recently it's not that
long ago yeah you know and i
i think it's um it's hard for people to
kind of really
recognize that and accept that so
because they feel like they're being
punished for what people have done in
the past
yeah which yeah we get that but we can't
be dismissive of what this country has
stood for for so [ __ ] long and it's
only been until recently that we're
trying you know
and even now until we talk about
equality but people don't see it now
even till this day
things are just kind of swept into the
rug yeah it's hard to deal with
i mean it reminds me of like i'm okay so
i don't know if this is a
side step but then i just finally
finished attack on titan
okay okay and i saw the the entire big
picture of what all this was about right
like the sins of the past like people
they don't even know or
are hardly connected to except by blood
or something
like i get it like should people today
have to pay for you know what happened
in the past or
is it going to continue this perpetual
cycle of just of hate
and war and killing do you know korean
people who just hate japanese people
like straight up
used to be me
yeah i had to be reformed i had to be
reformed there was this kid
named andrew jang and he hated japanese
people
this guy was the weirdest person i've
ever met but he'd always be like do you
know what they
did yeah sushi this guy
hated japanese people dude he hated all
like the third fourth generation
japanese people here that were like
their parents their grandparents were
internment camps it's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about dude they were
they were put in internment camps they
have nothing to do with what's going on
over there
but this will whenever the topic of like
japan came up
he would just flip the [ __ ] out he would
hate he hated them so much
i actually saw this dude's dick multiple
times i didn't want to see his dick
you know how i first met this fool so
so in korea we have like ginger buns
like saunas right so you know when
you're in the bathroom or your butt
naked or whatever
you know this is not how we do it in the
[ __ ] states yeah so this guy
i developed there's two people and i
mentioned this before i
that my kim jong-il character was
created from it was this guy andrew jang
and then my my uh komobu my uncle on my
on my dad's side
uh-huh uh so he this full
i i went into my friend's dorm uh my
buddy scott
lived into this in this dorm called ai
and i was spending the night over there
because i was like i'm not going to go
back to my dorm it's going to crash here
so i go into the bathroom to brush my
[ __ ] teeth and i see this dude butt
naked over a sink with his dick out
just no muscle on his body whatsoever he
just like a sack of jealous
and he's just brushing his teeth and his
little culture just whacking back and
forth
like a little puppy's tail just he's
like he's not moving the brush he's
moving
his body just just brushing his thing
that his dick just wiggling
and he turned it over and i look at him
i just go okay
close the door and then i go back and i
wait and that's the first time i ever
saw him
and because that was so traumatizing to
me i remember he came out the bathroom
he had a white wife beater on
blue basketball shorts these black
flip-flops and the towel and a white
towel over his neck
yeah and i just was traumatized i was
like what the [ __ ] happened to me twice
and then finally somebody came up to me
was like hey bro
no dick's out in the bathroom man yeah
like keep that in the shower this
is typically not what we do and he
learned it to learn the hard way this
guy was so
[ __ ] odd though because there was a
guy named daryl ajima
um he was he was uh one of the dorm
mates
japanese yeah fourth generation japanese
guy right
his his mom worked for the post office
and [ __ ] as american as it gets
and daryl would be trying to come into
the dorm room while we're kicking it and
talking right
so one night it was me our buddy young
and then a few other people i think was
scott and some other people we were
chilling in the dorm just chopping it up
just listening to andrew's like [ __ ]
stories about how cool he was in high
school
he was very obscure dude i'm talking
about this guy one time out of nowhere
he just goes
hey you want to see my girlfriend
wait is it is he bob from korea he's fob
do you want to see my girlfriend and it
goes okay well
show he he gets up super fast goes to
his closet brings out his yearbook
flips through the page picks the hottest
white girl he goes that's my girlfriend
okay
i'm like bro i've never seen somebody
lie so hard in my [ __ ] life
this is my girlfriend that's his voice
what do you like
he's a microprint right so
i lose this picture of this random hot
girl i'm like yo shut the [ __ ] up
because no this is my girlfriend
i'm like no it's not bro and this is the
conversation that we're having before
daryl comes in daryl lily walks in the
room
he looks at daryl's gym and he goes you
japanese get out
he goes get out and i'm like what the
[ __ ]
what's going on and then me and my buddy
young i'm looking at this like what's
wrong he goes he's a japanese
get out i don't like a japanese people
yeah because he he carried this
animosity and hate for japan because of
you know the korean pride or whatever
right right that's just who he was he
was very weird dude
i mean that's one thing to carry like
your parents or your grandfather's hate
with you
you know like i mean there's there's
inspiration to be had like
you know if he was if your grandfather
was a freedom fighter or yeah wasn't
that
but to carry along the hate that they
carried with them is uh
stupid dude this guy literally said the
most racist [ __ ] all the time
about the craziest things i'm telling
you because of him i probably own
royalties for kim jong-il
the first time we went to a walmart
right yeah out of nowhere
daryl is driving us i don't even think
he knows that daryl is japanese at this
point because this is when we first met
him and so we all went to walmart
together to get stuff for us
that we needed the dorms right daryl was
the one with the car
so we go to [ __ ] uh walmart and out
of nowhere i [ __ ] you not he goes
hey do you know why
there's a lot of black people have have
a kids
and we're like why teen pregnancy
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
this guy on right now and i'm looking at
like mad offended i'm like bro everybody
roll up the [ __ ] windows we're at
walmart right now
this guy's gonna get our [ __ ] ass
beat this dude was
weird dude this other dude named
herschel i remember one time because we
used to [ __ ] with this guy so much
because of how odd he was and he was mad
racist so
he got so mad because his dude herschel
went on photoshop and he put a picture
of
his face and superimposed it on this
this photo of dwyane wade duncan but he
put on dwyane wade's dick
low effort but high returns i returned
and this dude got picked
yeah i used to break a penis at my pace
what the what the hell man
but and you know he left his facebook
open so he put that as his profile pic
and it was just
him would [ __ ] you know hit him on
dwyane wade's dick so he comes out
and this guy used to always and this is
what i mean when
asian phrases and words like in korean
doesn't translate very well
like a very common phrase in korean is
like do you want to die
but he would always say that in english
to people so you look like a
psychopath do you want to die yeah so
with the herschel he goes hey
you want to die right you want to die
like what the [ __ ] is going on over this
very simple prank
but this is the threat that he gave to
him he goes you don't know
i'm a fourth degree black man
i'm a kicker you ass
this guy's so [ __ ] sad dude
do you know where i come from you know
from taekwondo
i'm gonna kick the u.s this fool used to
say the best phrases
there was this other guy named andrew
that was a part of this group called uh
kccc
right is that like a student association
korean christian crusaders for christ
stupidest [ __ ] names ever dude you
guys need some rebranding
but this guy andrew was also this other
angel was also very [ __ ] annoying
and they had this very serious
conversation while we were eating dinner
at the commissary
and this is what the conversation was
this is how [ __ ] ridiculous these
humans being human beings were
andrew tells him he goes you know i'm a
fourth degree black ben in taekwondo
and he goes like do what and this other
guy andrew's like what are you going to
do if i have a gun
because i'll just shoot you he goes no
i'm i'm a two pest
yo ed listen to this part he goes i'm
too passed
before you even shoot me i have a gun in
my hand
so they're demonstrating this at the
[ __ ] dinner table this is the one kcc
uh dinner thing i went to and i never
went again he goes
i'm gonna he goes fine this is a gun
this guy grabs a fork points there and
he grabs another hand he goes see
you're dead and they start arguing
about who would survive either this guy
with the gun or him
and his [ __ ] fourth degree taekwondo
black belt skills
they're legit arguing with each other
i'm like you guys are the two dumbest
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life
but then i've met people like that
except they were in their 40s oh my god
dude
he's like a youth pastor still i think
he's
hitting 50s now but he'd be the
craziest egomaniac narcissist
who was always talking about how he was
a gangpet in his high school
and like the stupid gang fights he would
have and
[ __ ] cares yeah it's like i don't think
any of us care about this
pastor i used to love that [ __ ] at
church when they would bring these
pastors
to like reform us he's like i used to be
in a gang
you know what i used to do i used to
kill people i was like dude
none of us here have a gang problem why
are you telling us this story
this is the wrong crowd bro dude we had
this guest pastor wants to
do a guest sermon and he's like
you know when i was in college i go to
the porsche dealership
to test drive you know the cars right
but then i drive it to uw
and just drive down the avenue with the
top down so people can see me
right and they're like okay
cool is that worrying about testimony
right and he's like you guys don't do
that
[Laughter]
okay what dude there are so many awkward
people man
bro i hold up my friends this podcast is
brought to you by ipvanish for those of
you who don't know ipvanish is a vpn or
a virtual private network that helps you
safely browse
the internet simply put if you are on
your computer doing just about anything
and you don't have a vpn by ipvanish you
are insane
people and webstupers are all up in your
business and i'm not judging anything
you're looking at online but that's your
business and your business alone
everybody else can kiss ass here's
everything you get with ipvanish
anonymous ip addresses this means your
personal ip address can't be tracked by
anyone on the web
circumvent any online censorship and get
protection when using
public wi-fi so basically nobody can
snoop on your data or see what you're
doing online
yes so go to ipvanish.combrain claim
your 65
savings they have plans starting at just
349 a month or 27.99
a year this is the time to sign up
ipvanish is the best of the best even
rated 4.7 out of five on trustpilot
and that's with more than 6000 reviews
so show these guys some love remember
it's ipvanish.com
brain to get the deal and start
protecting yourself online
today let me tell you this [ __ ] so
there's another kid he actually turned
out to be a really cool dude um
and this is where i wish i had a lot of
empathy when i was younger because
empathy
is very [ __ ] important yeah i would
have definitely talked to this guy
way differently and treated him way
differently if i was empathetic
right but instead i used to beat his ass
all the time so
i was going to say so but old david
and you know given he was very very
[ __ ] obnoxious
he knows how [ __ ] annoying he was too
because when he became really cool later
on i was able to talk to him and
converse with him
so at church he was
his father was uh a deacon right yeah
and this dude actually knew the bible in
and out
very [ __ ] well because his father
would you know force him to read the
bible
but because of his cockiness and his
knowledge of the bible
this dude would just he would either
choose to pretend like he didn't know
what he was talking about
or he would shove his christian
knowledge in everybody's face and
this dude was my age everybody used to
[ __ ] with this guy because he used to
get on everybody's nerve on purpose
right so there was this guy his all his
name was chris i think we used to call
him tank he was like half mexican half
korean
well during this time he was what three
or four years older than us so he was
our bible study teacher
right he was our interim bible study
teacher before somebody else came in
so one time and this was like my last
draw with him he used to do [ __ ] that
used to piss me off
but chris was making us go around and
just read a verse out of the bible
before we can continue bible study
so it comes to this guy his name is
daniel
i won't say his last name is a nice guy
but daniel is saying that he goes
i'm not going to read and we're just
like bro we just want to go and play
basketball just get out of here
yeah can you just finish up the verse
right and he just goes no i'm i'm not
going to read it
and then chris is like daniel can you
please read it like so we could just you
know we could finish up and then we
could move on it's important for
you know the small group thing he goes
i'm not going to do it he starts
laughing and smiling
oh god bro i got so [ __ ] mad
because i just wanted to leave and this
one he's arguing with daniel for like i
don't know like maybe 30 seconds or
it felt like an hour but it's probably
like 30 seconds yeah i got so [ __ ]
pissed and i still remember
because at the church we used to have
this like melon bar
colored chair that was plastic and then
it was these chrome handles
i grabbed literally the chair with him
in it i'm we're the same age
yeah i'm like [ __ ] 13 or 14. i'm this
size though
and i literally pick him up in the chair
i lift it up he's still in the chair and
i throw him out of the classroom with
the chair and i [ __ ] slam the door
and then we go back out and then we
start doing the church service again
i was so pissed i literally picked up a
dude
my age in the same chair and i chucked
him out of the butt and then this dude
chris was just shocked like oh he didn't
know what was going on i said bro just
[ __ ] finish up and read this
like just do it and then we finish it up
let me tell you how much of an [ __ ]
this dude was
this dude one time at church pissed off
this other fob
korean bible study teacher so bad the
guy kicked him out of this
he literally threw him out grabbed him
by the scuff of his shirt threw him out
and when he tried to get up he kicked
him in the ass again
and he flew out this guy was such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but i actually found out
when he became really cool and i
actually went back to the church later
on for some [ __ ] reason i don't know
why because i went to a different church
for a bit
and i met up with him i talked to him
and the reason why he was such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] was because he hated his life at
home
he didn't get along with his mom didn't
get along with his dad because his
parents
really focused on his younger daughter
his sister was a little brat
right and he resented his family so
[ __ ] much
so what happened was that he would put
all that resentment and angst and anger
into us so he would be an [ __ ] and
[ __ ] with us because at home he hated
being at the house
i didn't know so instead what i did was
i beat the living [ __ ] out of him every
week
i made it worse i was beating the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of this guy because he
was being an [ __ ] to me
but all it took for me was to ask him
what was going on and i never really did
that
well that's going to help me a lot to
walk through something i'm going through
right now
a few times a few weeks before i told
the story about
a christian artist sam och right about
this weird experience where
he tried calling me out for ruining
someone's career
you know and that's another weird
situation and then completely just
ignoring me the entire day and
i expressed my anger and on this podcast
just being like samuel if i see you i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up
you know in the blood of a jesus
um well you messaged me
he messaged me to apologize you know
he's like hey ed uh i saw that episode
with you on
davidson's genius brain and i just want
to say i'm sorry
you know because i was a jerk and like
full of you know his head was really big
because he was doing really well as an
artist at the time
and that he was just a hypocrite you
know
and then he said i really want to thank
david for having my back
but you didn't have to defend me
[Laughter]
but he's also said you know if there was
a way we could meet up and talk about
this than i would
but all i can say now is just like i'm
sorry you know that's really good of him
yeah and that i'm an inspiration to help
him lose weight or some [ __ ]
dude totally disarm me
but as i was texting back
everything i said was i don't give a
[ __ ] or
okay let me delete that if i see you nah
it's like man it's because of people
like i
don't i didn't have a response like
unless it was still
[ __ ] anger like i still don't know
what to say
you know and when you said about what
the hell was going on with that guy
back home and i guess acting like a brat
maybe acting like a sister was gonna
i don't know do something for him but
for me he should have changed his game
plan was like bro you literally got your
ass beat every sunday
he should have switched it up at least i
don't know if you're six
this is a different you know strategy
but
i started saying it was because i still
have this [ __ ] resentment over the
church
and like korean church people
specifically i think
i felt like maybe everything i want to
say about
my old home church or like the [ __ ] up
pastors i've had in my life
or you know the christian artists
who who [ __ ] like left like
really deceived me too you know like do
you know phil wickham is
yes i do i [ __ ] love his music dude
and i hate him i hate him as a person
really
i [ __ ] so i i use you know pro
presenter it's it's like powerpoint but
you can have like animated backgrounds
yes yes yes the lyrics on the screen i'm
pretty [ __ ] good at that [ __ ]
you know and um i did it for my friend's
album and whenever he do live shows so
he opened up for phil wickham
and so my friend had a really dope like
lyric screen as as he was performing
because i could sync the lyrics and
animation to him playing live
but when phil wickham went up it's his
wife is just kind of clicking next
next next and it's just black screen
with text
yeah so after the show phil wilcom is
like yo
can we sit down i'm like whoa you want
to talk to me yeah
like and he's like yeah dude you're
those lyric videos like that protein is
just like amazing
like i want you to go on tour with me
this summer you know i i want can you i
want you to create
animations for my lyrics i want you
because like i rely on this
you know because it's worship you know
everybody sings along but he wants to
have like a visual presentation
and he's just we're just chopping up and
i'm getting so much praise from this guy
he's like
ed i'm serious we're sitting like laptop
on this pew and he's like looking in the
eye
this is gonna happen i want to pay you i
want you to make videos for me i want
you to go on tour with me
and i'm also going to africa in august i
want you to be there with me and you
know
help me film the whole thing i was like
oh my god yes
yes i will you know this biggest
opportunity in my life
he goes that's great big fat hug shook
my hand he's like
it's gonna happen man you know and you
left for the rest of the tour um
no contact information
[Laughter]
i'm [ __ ] emailing this guy and his
record company
and i'm like getting i'm actually
packing my [ __ ]
yeah i'm getting ready to be gone for
months at a time on a tour bus
yeah you know um and i finally get a
hold of his
record label or his manager or something
and
i was like i said the whole story and
then they replied back
yeah that's not happening that was it
that was [ __ ] it
how random i know right so i think
all of that hate for like people like
him
[ __ ] other two-faced christian
artists i've met
um you know when you go out and you
actually like work in the christian
music industry like these people are
something like these people are [ __ ]
trash man yeah and
like because i've seen it within and how
crazy would it be
hey man i heard the jesus
hey listen i actually deal with crazy
anxiety and i was so embarrassed
[Applause]
get your [ __ ] number and i left that
i couldn't contact you back because i
was too embarrassed
i hit him up man i hit up every kind of
way of contact through his website or
his record label or whatever
and it was just like that's not
happening yeah and
i and i told that story of those three
pastors who [ __ ] like screwed me up
stupid [ __ ] thousand bucks you know
what it is too it's
for me and i know this sounds really
weird
right it's
i hold christian people to a higher
standard
because you put yourself there yeah you
put yourself there you're the one who
talks about
grace about love about kindness
so because that is the mantle that you
choose to be on like that's
you i'm gonna hold you to that [ __ ]
standard
so when you when somebody who's a piece
of [ __ ] does piece of [ __ ] things
i i'm not surprised right right but when
you're out in the forefront and you talk
about god's grace
god's love and this is who you are it is
a major part of your [ __ ] identity
yeah and then you do that type of stuff
of course it's going to sting a little
bit more
i'm going to remember it a lot more than
when that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] screwed
me over yeah because i almost expected
it out of them right
and then you learn a list like i
should've known better but i [ __ ]
trusted you a christian man yeah it's
like so when you know when when people
you know what it's there's just there's
layers to it it's almost
i feel like that person is being very
opportunistic about
you know he's like oh i know that i have
this christ thing so i can get to know
this person a little more and i could
probably ask them and they're a lot more
comfortable with me yeah and so you
almost feel taken advantage of they're
actually using their religion against
you
it's it's layers to the [ __ ] so
like recently too there was a um
they're not christian artists but they
were very forefront about their
christianity right
this whole scandal came out about them
you know them who they are too and i
love these people to death
they're really really good people but
the reason why they're getting crucified
so hard or what they did and why they
were so scared to to reveal
a lot of the bad stuff that they've done
in the past was simply because
they put themselves on this christian
pedestal so when you do that people
expect a certain thing out of you
right and so you know it was fear they
didn't want to talk about you know
all the dirt that they did in the past
like they had to deal with infidelity
and everything else
yeah um about them cheating and you know
all this like having kids out of wedlock
and stuff like that yeah it's like
well if you didn't put up this goody
two-shoes image
of yourself yeah if you didn't make
people feel like you were this perfect
human being whether you did it on
purpose or not
you wouldn't have to have felt that you
had to hide these flaws yeah
these flaws are inherently a human thing
yeah see because i could say right now
too people wonder on this podcast all
the time
david do you believe in god i do i grew
up as a christian my whole life
the problem with me is that or maybe not
the problem is that the reason why i
don't
shine it in front of everybody else is
because number one it makes me feel like
i'm [ __ ] on somebody else
it makes me feel like i'm saying i'm
better than you and i'm not if anything
else i'm probably just as bad or worse
yeah you know just it's the fact that
you're keeping it [ __ ] real
yeah you know you you walk your talk
you know and and you [ __ ] mean what
you say when you say it
you know and i think i just got so
[ __ ] tired because
you know where i'm coming from like i
sold my [ __ ] i was homeless on purpose
i went to these other countries and
stuff and
my whole reality breaking was just i'm
coming home back to other christians
and they're too scared or they don't
want to do the things
and so i question why i even did the
things i did like what is a christian
you know and so you know i
i would try to you know i was trying to
get into
doing like christian music industry
stuff before i did
any like whatever i'm doing now and
just meeting like i said shitty artists
like look samok's
literally working with a guy i
personally [ __ ] hate too from seattle
you know and that was another thing like
i wanted to oh and that guy you're
working with like wait he doesn't need
to know that
yeah but i have major [ __ ] beef with
him and
this [ __ ] guy so while i was still in
washington at my store
had the [ __ ] gall to ask me to help
him out with this next music video and
it's like
dog i [ __ ] hate you because of the
music videos we've done
yeah man like he doesn't seem to see
that we ever had a problem he just like
swept it under the rug
you know and i would just
i guess i was just getting triggered by
sam just for being who he is but then
i'm like blinded by that rage like i
can't get over
like i don't know how to just be like
yeah it's cool it's like because i don't
feel like it's cool
and once again it's you know i think it
has a lot to do with you know you expect
something better from somebody like that
yeah and then it's just it's cyclical
like you've seen this happen to you so
many times
and so it's just like the last straw
it's like why the [ __ ] is it that every
[ __ ] christian person i meet
these christian artists who are supposed
to be this this example
of holiness yeah falls so far from grace
but they get to still
you know gallivant around as if they are
holy like what the
there's hypocrisy in it and that's the
part that bothers me they they live
off of god's grace because god is
forgiving them right and
so the idea is this like if i was still
a
hardcore practicing christian then
i'm supposed to forgive sam because
christ
died for me right he's forgave my sins
therefore
who am i to be unforgiving right
but when i let go of all that a very
unhealthy thing happened
i lost my concept of forgiveness
you know and i don't know how to forgive
people anymore
because christ used to be the arbiter
between you know
our beef but now i'm like he's out the
picture
now it's just you and me [ __ ]
you know yeah how about
what what is the apology without jesus
kind of thing and but he did he said it
he said we actually didn't have much to
do about jesus he just said he was a
hypocrite
you know what i don't know why i can't
get over it i don't know if i
you know when you when you say that i
don't know if i really forgive
people i think i have an ability to say
you're dead to me
and then i move on i just go oh you're a
piece of [ __ ]
you're dead there are some people too
they don't understand they think this is
heartless there's a lot of people i know
that that i know but people i don't like
if they die tomorrow
i'd have no problem [ __ ] on their
grave
it's kind of like when i see a dead cat
lying i don't even like cats
[Laughter]
i i could literally people get so turned
off by that they go
why would you say such a thing it's like
because i don't [ __ ] care about you i
actually
dislike you there are there are a few
people in this entertainment
entertainment space if they [ __ ] die
tomorrow i'd be like bro i hope i get to
see your grave so i could make a picnic
on it
and so much more oxygen to have for
myself
now that you're not i would have a
picnic on your gravesite and eat the
foods that you hated the most
[Laughter]
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] i know quite a
few people like that
yeah but for me like and i always talk
about like forgiveness is healing right
if you can't truly forgive somebody
it you know it makes you feel better
because it's not on your heart and your
conscience anymore
yeah that's why i i've done it so well
maybe my version of forgiveness is more
like
i just don't have space for it's gone
yeah like i literally feel nothing about
when you succeed
whether you fail anything about it i
feel absolutely
nothing right like you know okay i think
my
my concept of forgiveness is like i said
still stuck on
the way christianity goes about
forgiveness
you know and i just couldn't get over
the hump of
how do you even forget how am i gonna
[ __ ] forget this [ __ ]
you know um also too it's just like you
know
forgiveness also has to do with an idea
of of grace right
let's say aside from god right it's like
would you want somebody to be able to
forgive you the same way that you could
forgive this person
right right right if you truly became a
better person than you apologized
it would be nice if that person forgives
you or not the difference is
is that the power is really within you
you don't have to forgive somebody
right just because somebody apologizes
doesn't mean you have to accept it
whether that person feels a certain way
about it or not they go well that's
unfair
doesn't [ __ ] matter you do not you do
not say sorry expecting that person to
forgive you
you say sorry because you know that you
[ __ ] up and that's where you leave it
at so you know the forgiveness part is
completely up to you
whether you want to or not it's just
that i know that when you do forgive it
just feels better
right it feels better for you you know
yeah i'm even reading like a self-help
book about it and then it's just
like their forgiveness things yeah just
forget it like this [ __ ] doesn't [ __ ]
happen
you're gonna have to let it go what the
[ __ ] like what am i right yeah
what is this
you know i i think to disarm myself
too like yeah i think the [ __ ]
threats i made
were like a projection of just what i
want to say to other people and all the
people that hurt me it's not like
what he did really [ __ ] my [ __ ] up you
know
um it was just like that anger i had
just carried on
and just i just pointed it at him yeah
right and that's
at least the kind of piece i can go
towards be like i don't think i really
meant i was gonna [ __ ] this guy up yeah
i just had this anger and it went
on him i just don't even like being
angry anymore that's why you know just
to go back to what we were talking about
before like the the the trauma porn yeah
it's it's hard for me to do that now
it's hard for me to get super angry
because it
literally eats away at my very soul
like it kills me on the inside it feels
like i'm rotting on the inside
and that and every time i watch more of
it i want to watch i will watch it i
want to watch it more
and more no matter how it makes me feel
it actually makes me feel [ __ ]
terrible
and it doesn't cause me to do stuff for
positive change so what am i really
doing here
yeah you know like i just hate feeling
that way see then that's
now my problem right it's not like
i have sam och porn i'm sorry that was
sounding bad
sam ah contest christian music with your
dick
on an acoustic guitar slam out content
it's not like i'm scrolling through as
[ __ ] you know it's not like i'm like
you know actively looking at what he's
up to or whatever
um it's just in my head it's just layers
of it yeah i'm just getting into my own
you know time machine in my brain or
just putting in the movie again
and replaying what made me angry like
even getting it's weird because now i
like i probably will never ever get into
a fight right but there's moments where
i get
really uh disappointed in myself when i
get [ __ ] angry because i had to go
through like
anger management and counseling because
i didn't know how to deal with my
[ __ ] rage
and um there are flashbacks of of my
life when i was younger
where i remember just going red and
it's bad you know there was this one
time when i was in high school and i
always
when i get irritated and mad that's why
like even when marielle and i used to
fight a lot i always tell her give me
space
because i need the space because i need
a nuke yeah because i'm gonna [ __ ]
explode
you know not hurt her but just like hurt
myself i'll punch a wall i'll break
something you know
it's stupid [ __ ] you know but like there
was this one time i remember
i i just i was kind of like sick of
getting bullied so much
and so at this point it's like you know
what anybody can [ __ ] get it i don't
give a [ __ ] right and so i was
there's this am pm really close to my
house i used to get like arizona iced
teas at
all the time after i played basketball
yeah well one time i was there with a
couple of homies and these weren't like
high school friends they were friends
that i grew up um
near my parents store and you know
they're very bad people but when you're
like around this group of people and we
were talking about this with the china
mac podcast help
you kind of emulate their behaviors but
because i felt like such an
insignificant
insecure little [ __ ] i always had a
one-up and do more things right yeah and
that would just lead to just me being
unnecessarily angry all
the [ __ ] time because i always
thought there was somebody who looked
who thought of me as lesser than
who thought they could punk me and bully
me yeah i should you [ __ ] not
i'm sure i told this on the podcast well
this is a big part of my shame so when i
get angry i always think about this time
of how uncouth and how uncultured and
how stupid i was
there's this dude and when you when i
tell the story
you might think that this guy deserved
it because just i was walking outside
and i was remember i was wearing this
like big baggy pink t-shirt it was like
a pink t-shirt and at the time wearing
pink wasn't really cool yeah but what i
like pink and so i was wearing that [ __ ]
and i was walking outside the am pm this
guy walked at me what's up [ __ ]
calls me a fact i don't even blink i
turn around and i just start
wailing on him i'm talking about fist to
his [ __ ] teeth
i cracked his face so [ __ ] hard i
actually knocked out either like the
side tooth or it was like the two front
teeth and i just kept wailing on him
and the only thing i could think about
was number one i don't even think i was
that angry
was number one i got angry because the
idea that somebody out there could think
that i'm a little [ __ ] and he was doing
in front of these people who were i was
trying to prove
myself that was something that i wasn't
and i think about that type of rage and
i get embarrassed and i get ashamed
so like when i think about anger and
rage i always go back to that one moment
where i remember after that two by the
way i went home and i cried
like i cried because i was like what the
[ __ ] are you doing like why are you
why did you do that like you literally
just beat the [ __ ] out of this guy i
never died or i couldn't be in jail
i could have killed that guy for what
for what the [ __ ] was i doing but i used
to be so
angry all the time i hate anger i don't
like being angry anymore
and i did that just to prove a [ __ ]
point like what was the point of this
yeah like why am i so mad all the time
sometimes when i think of that [ __ ]
haunts me because it's like dude i
literally mauled this dude for no
[ __ ] reason be quiet because he
called me a [ __ ]
yeah you know what was the what was the
point of this why did you do that
when i look at anger i look at stupidity
now it's like unless it's like directed
at the right place
i'm creating content i'm doing something
purposeful with it yeah but when i
carry rage like that for no reason it
reminds me of a time where i was really
stupid
so i don't like being angry anymore
because it makes you do dumb things when
i get mad
like that i start feeling uh
disappointed in myself
because i remember that time where i
punched this dude i literally beat the
[ __ ] out of this guy and by the way
i don't feel good about it either
because he wasn't even near my size
he was like a dude that was like maybe
five foot seven five foot eight i'm like
six one and i
wake up on this dude i beat this [ __ ]
out of them for no [ __ ] reason
yeah so when i think about rage i think
about how stupid it is like this is dumb
most people talk about fights when
people confront you like that you can
walk away most of the time
99.9 percent you can walk away yeah
edric told this one [ __ ] story where
there's these vatos that were sitting
outside of a liquor store edric had his
socks rolled up all the way high
like walked up he goes what's up fool
what the [ __ ] your socks so high for
the roll them down you know what edric
did [ __ ] roll this socks down
and he went in and he got his [ __ ]
drinks okay yeah
you know rage it just it eats away at
you it just i don't want to do anything
in life that
takes away from me anymore i just refuse
yeah i
don't want to do it anymore it's like
the same reason why i lost weight why
did i carry this weight here
it's eating away at me just these are
these excuses that i make about why i'm
big why i want to stay fat
same thing with rage it just takes too
much anger takes
too much for me and i get nothing in
return i literally get nothing
that's true i guess what my excuse is is
justice like but this happened to me and
it wasn't fair he's he's five foot two
god got him yeah
he's a nice little five foot two guy
he's shaped like a lego was it
like no so yeah that's what i mean like
why am i so angry at
him and yeah i don't think it's him it
was just
my rage against the church and
christianity all around in general the
quote-unquote christian industry too
that i think that's what i'm carrying
and the excuse also being that like
i don't want to let go of this
resentment until i see blood but it's
like is that true man
i mean we we think that but every time
you're not ever going to be satisfied
yeah let's say whatever sense of justice
that you have it gets fulfilled
well what you're going to get angry
about something else then you're going
to have to quench that sense of justice
again
over and over and over and it's it's a
never-ending well you just can't fill
this well up
it doesn't happen that way you know yes
that's why now when i get angry i just
i literally just have to let it go
because i know for a fact i have a very
short amount of time on this earth
if i carry every second that i waste
being mad at somebody they're
literally taking away from me it's like
it's like those kids that we make fun of
online where i make a joke or a comment
or i have an opinion about something
they disagree with
and i find it hilarious that they're
sitting there in their room brewing and
upset
that they have to type this thing that
they want me to [ __ ] die and it makes
me laugh
but i've now taken away joy from them
yeah
that they can't get back and it makes me
laugh i refuse to give that to somebody
else
right so i guess
what i ultimately have to do is just
grow the [ __ ] up
i mean it's so weird because the
simplistic solution is what that book
says right you just have to learn
how to let it go yeah but i think for me
i'd look at it as
it's not so much just letting go to it's
like this is better for me
like i'm gaining something now rather
than losing time wasting it on this
[ __ ] that's why now on the podcast i
mentioned it before i like positive
comments
because those people are the ones that
deserve my attention even ones that they
disagree with what i'm saying i still
like it yeah as long as somebody's not
calling me a [ __ ] loser or some
weird [ __ ] i'm not gonna like their
comment you know it's probably because
i'm like recognizing the radicalization
of me
where i was so [ __ ] hardcore
christian
and now i'm like you know what i
actually made a vow
i made a vow when i left the church
where i was like
none of these [ __ ] christians i know
know a goddamn [ __ ] thing about jesus
yeah none of them actually know a thing
about theology or even salvation
you know and i literally said
i vow to take down every fake [ __ ]
christian i see
with the knowledge i have of how the
bible actually you know what it means
and what it says
and what jesus means kind of thing
i that's the crazy part that's supposed
to be the word of life
against them yeah yeah like i'll try to
pull up verses to
show how [ __ ] fake christians are you
know
um and i i okay
so i'm gonna tell this story the first
time i was on
your podcast i told this story about
those pastors and
what i experienced leaving my church
because i was i had a bad drug problem
and
they didn't do a goddamn [ __ ] thing
even though i confessed these things
and that's where i was just like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] them all
but this one kid he's like 22.
his his name is ed park okay right
super nice kid really great kid and he
texted me and he's like i heard the
podcast like so crazy i didn't know
any of this about you that's that's the
general
um kind of message i got from the old
church people was like
whoa ed we didn't know you went to iraq
or we didn't know you
did we didn't i was like you guys never
asked me i was gone for a year
none of you guys wanted to get to know
me yeah and i always just stood in the
back and then
what i heard from people was like oh
that's ed he's a christian but he like
cusses a lot
you know and he smokes hey [ __ ] you guys
in the blood of jesus christ [ __ ] you
god loved the world
so [ __ ] much that he gave his one and
only [ __ ] son
yeah you know and and i i was so upset
like that man you guys couldn't do the
basic thing of asking me for my
testimony and now you guys are shocked
about everything i know
and you want to get to know me now and i
was so resentful of that
and then i actually went off on this kid
about that i was like dude why didn't
you just [ __ ] ask me you know
i was like now like look at me like you
could be me in 15 years dude
like either you can grow up and be a
faithful man
or you look at me just be a drug addict
[ __ ] degenerate you know who vows to
take down
christians and i told him too it's like
i know the bible
way more than you you know like what are
you gonna do about it
and i said this [ __ ] to him that
probably questioned his existence
yeah you know um but his answer was like
well i guess i should read the bible i
need to learn theology
you know i was like yeah good don't be
ed park me
in the future it's like you have a way
better chance if you do it the right way
man
you know you know it's also it also kind
of brings up the subject in the topic
of you know what's better is it better
to know christ as when you're when you
didn't know him
growing up or do you is it better to
know christ just when it was forced upon
you as a kid
right because a lot of these kids who
grew up in this church they don't know
god
they don't know god they don't know
scripture they don't know theology
because it was a given to them
you are in my family thus you believe in
god yeah there are people who have
accepted like christ later on in life
whether they have that epiphany or or
a revelation to them and they seek god
in a different way
or we could call it god or truth or
whatever the [ __ ] that it is
right where they needed it right they
they needed an answer
or they had a crisis or whatever they
needed hope
you know those things like where that
they rest in and then there's
literally 90 plus percent of them like
who just like hey they could have grown
up in a buddhist family and just felt
the exact same way about buddhism right
yeah yeah
just depending on their environment or
who they were born to like the weird
thing is for me is like my biggest
aversion towards christianity is
christians
yeah isn't that crazy that's why i hate
going to church because i have to be
around these people
yeah it's like they come up to me and
you know they're like hey how are you
you should come to our small group
and then the first thing i want to say
is like i will break your [ __ ] teeth
and get away from me it's just you can
like
feel the fakeness or you can feel this
forced thing like you say this every
week to everybody
yeah and you just hope that there's a
chance that somebody will show up
that's like you know one of the guys
from the pickup
whatever people oh yeah yeah i remember
i was hanging out with one of those guys
with abe and everywhere we went
he would hit up on every girl and like
same pickup line
same thing all that and to them it's a
game of statistics like if i hit up a
hundred girls
one girl would say yes yeah so
and that's like if christians you take a
good look at yourself about the way you
go about doing your pick-up artist
pick-up artist
yeah it's it's weird like because even
when you bring that up like there's a
church that i like to go to
um when they were open is and the
biggest reason why
is because they don't talk to me yeah
i go in pressure i'll say hi i'll say
good morning
you know that feels great but when they
start pressuring me to come into small
group and also stuff and tell me what i
should or shouldn't do
that's where i draw the line i'm like i
come here because i want to
listen to the scripture yeah and i want
to learn these life lessons and it makes
me feel good
the moment they start coming to me and
they're like yo come over to small group
i'm like i will break your legs
i don't know it's just this weird space
i have with my faith like i just
i like christianity i
don't like the people right and i don't
know how that works for me
so part of my therapy um when i was
leaving washington
was yeah the radicalization where i was
just so
[ __ ] angry and done with this racism
[ __ ] that
i started recognizing my generalization
of
just white people in general you know
where i can't trust nobody
none of them none of them are good and
like wait that's not [ __ ] true
you know it's like two [ __ ] [ __ ]
made me angry today out of the
hundreds that came through you know so
one of the things i talked to my
therapist was just like i don't want to
be a racist
you know and i can see my little ticks
of it like the generalization
just the resentment and the anger and
things
and what they suggested was like yeah so
you just have to meet
good white people in your life and put
more focus on them
which is why i hang out with dan all the
time yeah but that's barely why did that
feel
so
he's all bread on the outside yeah but
uh
but yeah like um in the other case too
just
dealing with like why the [ __ ] am i so
angry at this guy
i was like telling myself maybe i need
to
put more focus on the good christians
that are out there hard to [ __ ] find
the good christians that are out there
you're my friend sam mock
i'll tell you what no i met a guy at
kenny's house
uh he's a pastor at a pretty major
church uh here in l.a
and i didn't even know he was a pastor
there and we were just chilling talking
hanging out and i was sharing
and we talked about christianity too i
didn't even know he was a pastor of this
church
and he was the coolest dude and talking
me through it
and then i looked at his instagram he's
the pastor of a major church
you know he's like [ __ ] and he still
keeps in touch with me he's like he's a
great guy you know yeah like focus on
that there are good christians out there
yeah not that it's going to like make me
want to go back and like
do that crazy lifestyle again but then
that yeah i want to suggest you going on
a nomad in cro like korea and like a
nomadic journey
getting kicked out of churches from
church you know left and right
i would never do that [ __ ] even in my
crazed moments of like
uh my hardcore belief no that's not
happening
they're like hey do you believe in god
i'd be like yes i do believe in god do
you really believe in god david i
100 do i want you to go to korea and i
want you to walk around from church and
church i'm like listen
there are other religions out there
that do not require me to do this crazy
talk what are you talking about
i feel like now because i've experienced
so many different type of people like
you know
i think that if i wanted to be like a
racist i could be the best racers ever
it seems easy to be that dumb right yeah
you just have to say like the most
ridiculous [ __ ]
dude i remember just well sometimes when
i go online and i
hear how racism and almost stupidity
kind of go hand in hand
yeah right yeah like the way like
there's so many like logical fallacies
in how they think
but there's a lot of people who kind of
corroborate their thoughts that make
them believe that they're the smartest
person in the room
like you you'll hear like this is not
this by the way is nothing that i've
read before but it'll be like some [ __ ]
like
i don't know it's like my name is cletus
and i'm here to talk about
diversity well a lot of homosexuals
talking about
diversity don't they well how diverse is
it
to being a couple with two dicks
[Laughter]
people will be like well that's the
smartest thing i've ever heard in my
life
it's a confirmation by a soup yeah yeah
yeah and there's a circle jerk there's
jerking each other off right
like like i make a joke about that but
that's the type of [ __ ] that you see
online and they have like thousands of
[ __ ] lives like yeah
how diverse is that guess they don't
like their own [ __ ] medicine kind of
tastes a little bitter dead
i think diversity is when you have a
vagina and a penis
in one [ __ ] couple two separate
things you don't put
the the gasoline pump into the exhaust
pipe
okay a real pastor said that once uh
dude famous one judah smith justin
bieber's pastor i used to go to his
youth group bro
oh my god i heard him say that [ __ ] dude
i heard he brought in a guest speaker
this crazy dude from louisiana and like
um he was just [ __ ] ragging on rosie
o'donnell he's like
how bear rosie donald
point her fat finger and judge the
president
of the united states george w bush he is
my friend
and he is a man of god right and then he
go off like
evolution how can evolution be true
do you know how complicated the human
eyeball is
you know evolution says that a swamp can
produce
a beautiful coke can what and i'm like
that is not fun
and he'd say [ __ ] like you know if if
someone in your family or your friends
are dying of cancer
it's because they have no faith you need
to have
faith you know guess what his wife died
of cancer
get the [ __ ] out of it i read in the
news oh my god did he go because my wife
was a [ __ ] charlatan
yeah he should right if you want to
follow your theology never [ __ ]
believe that's why she got the
titty cancer
she got she got the mastectomy that's
the problem with her right for [ __ ]
titties didn't believe in jesus christ
yeah and so
all these crazy [ __ ] and stories like i
i guess i'm like still holding on with
the anger part
of that you know i mean that [ __ ]
doesn't make me angry it's just
ridiculous
and like funny to tell now but
yeah i'm i to get over it is definitely
more or less now
a maturity thing i think yeah for my
peace of mind because
you think you're still hurting like the
same 23 year old
yeah you know that's probably what's
going on i mean you're gonna
i mean it's easier said than done but
you know you're gonna have to let it go
eventually
yeah i mean we're in our 30s now like
what the [ __ ] the word
yeah it's sam like just give me a minute
to respond all right just give me a
second dude just
write a song about it and then we will
talk about it yeah we'll probably get
over that someday
i mean you'll be fine man i think like
you're you're in this weird phase where
i think you just moved back to l.a and
now you have time to kind of think about
these thoughts that you weren't allowed
to think about before because you ought
to worry about your mom you got to worry
about the store
you had to worry about some dudes trying
to rip your balls off
in the middle of a liquor store there's
like but
this is what pandemic did to a lot of
people though all these times that we
were able to distract
ourselves by doing activities hanging
out with friends
drinking going out was taken away from
us
right there are so many people now
during this pandemic
that have it forced them to think yeah
they
didn't have that time before they're
left in this room they're left in this
house
they're like okay well now that i can't
go out i'm left with these thoughts that
i have to face
face to face and and it [ __ ] bothered
them right
you know i think for me like i do it so
often now pandemic didn't
really do much to me right it just made
me go oh okay i just have to make a
shift but other people it really made
them look in a mirror
they had to be faced with themselves it
was hard for a lot of people it happened
to a lot of people's relationships
happened to me and mariel's relationship
during this pandemic we almost broke up
because of it
so that's that that truth revealing
process that you're going through right
now is just very sudden and it's
very very concentrated yeah it's raw you
know
fresh you're in your own place now
right and you're you're left with these
thoughts and sometimes like being left
with your thoughts is a very scary thing
i think that's why sometimes
every that's why people distract
themselves with their phones people
can't be left alone with their thoughts
they have to be on their phone even me
now i have to shower i bring my phone in
me
how come i can't just not look at this
stuff yeah it's because i want to
distract myself from
real work or real real ideas you know
that's true
nah and and one of the biggest things
that i realized too is
that everyone's going crazy not crazy
but
everyone's going through a maybe a
situation like
this you know because yeah everyone had
to deal with this pandemic
and that i'm not alone you know but then
the healthy process is what so many
people just don't know
right and i think that's what scares me
too that i'm just like
feeding myself hate you know
and i'm trying to find a healthy way
through being in my own thoughts because
i'm just stuck with them
right we're all stuck with it yeah yeah
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain
podcast i hope you guys took something
away from this
samuel och my friend my good friend
i know there's two podcasts out here
where you got shot on
you it's not totally your fault he's
dealing with a lot of stuff brother
sam will be on this podcast when he's in
town yeah i mean great musician by the
way he makes
great producer you guys see all of his
stuff but um
jesus brain podcast every thursday and
sundays and you can catch ed at ed
parkvp at all platforms and we'll see
you all next time
peace peace